hello and welcome to understanding
audience experiences on Google cloud
platform my name is Sarah Gupta and I'm
a customer engineer at Google cloud for
media and entertainment media streaming
has a global audience with wide
variances in device types user locations
connection bandwidths and user behaviors
today I'll be talking about large-scale
media analytics for digital streaming
and how Google clouds products can make
it easy to ingest analyze and get
insights at scale from millions of users
watching your content this demo shows
the power of Google clouds fully managed
enterprise data warehouse bigquery along
with Google clouds fully managed
enterprise data visualization tool
called looker to explore the media
audience experience and answer the
question how many people are finishing
their videos over the past few days
members of my team have been watching
various short movies events are emitted
from the shaaka player running in the
browser being used for these movie
watching sessions these events are
transmitted to a ninja standpoint
running on the cloud run serverless
platform the events are in queued on to
pub/sub which is a fully managed global
event streaming system dataflow is a
unified stream and batch data processing
service based on a patch a beam dataflow
uses the event stream from pub/sub as a
data source and inserts the data into
bigquery looker is then used to
visualize the data and get meaningful
insights from it so over to the demo
[Music]
here you can see a simulation of a
streaming services video library just as
what a streaming customer might be
expected to see in their streaming
service as a user I can select any movie
to watch before we begin let us activate
the browser's debug window so we can see
the events that are being emitted for
analytics
let me now select one of my favorite
movies camon on des the video starts
playing in the video page and a sample
pre-roll ad starts before the video you
can see the different ad quartile events
being emitted let me click on the ad
which takes me to the ads details page
where a customer would likely see the
details of the ad they've just clicked
on let's return to the video and
continue playing as expected other
events continue to fire let me mute and
you can see that event being emitted and
let me pause the video and again all
these events are streaming directly into
bigquery
so let's take a look at bigquery here is
where the events would land in a
specific data set I can run a sample
query to see these events land in
bigquery in near-real-time this query
shows me all the events that have
accumulated in the past one minute
including the events related to pausing
the ad and pausing the video as I
assured them on the player all of these
events can be analyzed in looker using
visual dashboards let's take a look at
that
here is the media event analytics
dashboard that we've created in looker
based on the data in bigquery up here
you can see the total number of events
that we have logged the number of
sessions we've encountered this month
and most importantly the viewership
funnel which shows us the progression of
fuschia from one quartile of the video
to the next so we can see the number of
starts midpoints and completion of
videos we can also see where customers
are watching the videos in in a map view
additionally we can also see the device
break down and get session level details
further down we can also break down the
add funnel in terms of how many ads or
started how many were completed and how
many were clicked through we can also
get details on a particular asset and
drill into that so here let's select
Syntel and see the details of what this
specific asset is collecting from an
analytic standpoint again the data that
we got at the coarse grain gross level
we can now drill down at a finer level
and get details about this specific
video in terms of how many events were
issued against it how many sessions the
viewership funnel the completion rates
devices ads sessions and also geographic
distribution let us now return to the
presentation
as you just saw the query and looker
provide a unified view of data across
ads players and other sources of data
regarding your streaming platform
bigquery and Locker offers self-service
access to key insights for the very
stakeholders thus allowing better and
more timely decision-making and since
these are fully managed service
components you're freed from the
overhead of managing infrastructure and
can focus on running your business
bakery and lucre make it powerful
combination for streaming media
analytics allowing you to unify
analytics across ads content viewers and
other sources derive meaningful insights
in minimal time leading to deep
understanding of the audience experience
for actionable outcomes thanks for
watching
understand the user experience on Google
Cloud Emma please visit cloud at
google.com slash solutions slash media -
entertainment for more details and other
solutions for media on Google Cloud
[Music]